so because because I personally I was
not interested in oh by the way you guys
know debrief afterwards okay otherwise
took us forever to get through this I
did not really want to say that why he
call this therefore this week was there
and I didn't have quite enough space
unless i wrote really small to say this
right that I think that by the way
that's the next best thing but uh maybe
the best thing but anyway this is what I
elected to do you go your functions
there so here at our derivatives for
cost 4 x 3 e to the X 1 plus X just know
here right you guys i hope i've heard me
say this enough times you look at the
question is factorization necessary here
yes this factorization necessary yeah
yeah
now let's point out right because I want
you guys to not just be I've said this
many times I don't want you just to be
you know machines that are just after
marks and I come here I want you
mathematicians simplify excuse me we
know simplify we know is a dangerous
word we kind of have to have it because
it does catch everything that we need
where you see you know where necessary
right I don't think uh let's just write
this without having a factorize it I
don't think three e to the X plus three
X DX is necessarily all that much worse
than what I've written over here in this
context right now it would be a
completely different matter if part two
was let's find the stationary points
okay clearly then factorize it is of an
advantage but here you know at different
points in your mathematical career
simplified doesn't mean factorize
simplify means expand right simplify
means everything so in this case don't
take off any marks if it's not
factorized I factorize because well you
need to meet yet it is prettier how you
knit you do need to be good at
factorizing so there's no reason not to
practice that's cool okay I 2 x 1 x
squared minus 9 yeah 3 plus 6 squared
and then here's my use of parole are you
happy with all those looking good cool
yeah at that time
okay so what did i do here what was my
technique for going through this
question what was I trying to identify I
was trying to identify f dash on F
that's what I'm looking for right I it's
tricky now now that we know the more
knowledge you have the more you kind of
have to sift through a bit wait is this
is it in verse 10 okay because you see X
Squared's and stuff on the bottom it's
not investor you need to be able to tell
the difference between them I multiply
through by a half head to just so I got
the numerator exactly like a 100 but if
you went straight here that's okay
that's all right ah here's my definite
integral so again I've elected to the
one-third three business you have a look
at that denominator sorry not that to
donated my final ants are again I just
left it like that rather take you out an
additional factor what do you think
therefore that what do you think do you
think this is better what am I going to
get eaters what do you think
like you how did you have bad you oh ok
you had another step yeah okay hi I'm
gonna go ahead and say I think for I did
that right yeah come on yeah yeah okay
um I'm going to say I think this line is
fine okay because if they where could
this possibly go where could this
question go unlike the previous question
where it's at our sole for something
there's nothing left to solve for that's
just a number like you're not going to
say oh I can factor and fine with that's
equal 0 it better not be equal to 0 it's
a value if i go to my calculator is it
faster to enter in this line versus this
line it's there looks to be pretty much
identical because you're gonna have to
do e to the something twice anyway so i
think it's fine and i think it's a
little excessive to go difference of
squares on that next lab but they do it
okay let's go over here I straight
difference of cubes here's my solution
now you can see this is what do we what
we call these what do we what do we do
we give these things we call them
equations that are it's not a quadratic
but it's reducible to a quadratic which
is why I've been gone ahead and done and
factorize just like I would for a normal
quadratic obviously you could do a
substitution if you like but it just
takes me a couple extra lines okay here
12
you guys though I watch you to discuss
this and debrief this I want you to have
that conversation just not right now
while I'm explained it to okay now it is
critical it's critical that this is
somewhere in this if this was two blocks
one of the marks would be there right
you cannot simply a go to this slide
that's a big big daughter and even even
doing this it's better than going than
skipping the two solutions but it's
still a bit if away yeah like you
understand why tell me why and there are
different reasons for why at different
points so i think i think you should
really have it in for there and then of
course you take logs of both sides and a
key log to ah that was just this was
that do I river by Sigma notation my
question okay 27 yeah can I go like a
really big number sure
so just to remember and hopefully be
writing it whoops I didn't want to raise
hopefully be writing it like this makes
it clear this is an AP right so if it's
like Oh from 3 to as the kid was just
suggesting 500 okay that's a different
question we get that is not going to be
worth one mark that's testing something
else isn't it that's testing do you
recognize that it's an AP and then do
you know what to do with that and use
the right formula etc okay there for
what it's worth I mean you could still
you didn't have to use the formula you
can say if it's a teepee I could do
first to the last term and they take the
average of however many players there
are right so you know what to do okay
let's have a look at this guy so here's
my here's my answer to pilot three
people happy with that yep or Hydra 20
degrees is fine there's nothing that
forces you into either situation I will
point out because before you launch into
your work E it's important you see
what's going on right the size of the
largest eagle is attached to its going
to be opposite the larger side enjoy the
diagram makes that very very obvious
right even if you didn't see that
immediately okay so you got to hit draw
that it tells you where you are so you
know that you want C or B or whichever
angle you leave it to be the opposite
one yep yeah you could on in fact the
first time I write these solutions I
literally wrote here sorry just above
before i start the cosine rule i would
say the largest angle is opposite blah
blah blah blah blah so that sentence
sort of act as this diagram for me
though I would say just looking at this
question based on two marks no one's
going to lose marks for not including
that line but like I said we want to
sound bad petitions not just good for
the back so I think that's a great thing
to include that all the diagram
uh-oh I think I had radians there before
and I accidentally rubbed it off you can
just write to you pile three keep on
three is fine but being that here I
presented the contrast of two things
I've just named it okay all right now
for the geometry question I am very open
to if someone has a faster proof for
this because this is not the fastest
proof this is just the first proof that
I thought of does that look how about
now just let me explain I'll show you
the way by late I mean we've done we've
got 70 geometry questions um it's worth
me look at this again because you know
we forget this as extension students
here's the way like go right back to
nuts and bolts right here's the way I
approach a question like this okay I
pretty much figure that personally I've
got like a ten to fifteen percent chance
max at starting to write down stuff and
picking a reasonably efficient path
right from the beginning right Ferb life
oh yeah I know what I riding over here
and I take a good path through I think
it's much more efficient for me just
like you know when you spend reading
time planning out your essay right I go
to my diagram and hey if you don't have
a diagram for a decent diagram and I
think okay what am I going to work with
here okay i want this triangle over here
to be equilateral there are two paths to
proving that a triangle is equilateral
they are angles and sides right I want
all the angles i will all the sides
which one's going to be easiest to
minute okay now i look at this and i
think yeah probably got to be angles
right so the reason i'm thinking that is
because this parallelogram gives me lots
of equal angles all over the place gives
me equal size to which I'm going to use
but it's harder to get to some of these
without going by angles first so you
might as well do angles so therefore
having thought about that he was the
path my brain took I said okay parallel
parallel that gives me this angle over
here which means again using the same
parallel lines that gives me the angle
over here yep follow with me again going
back to the parallelogram this equal
side over here equals this too so now I
know it's at least it's isosceles if
it's isosceles I've got equal angles
opposite equal science
the suegros gives me the third eagle or
i could any part that life I've got the
angles I've done okay so here's my
wording down this is three marks what do
you think we're looking for what kinds
of properties are going to get used by
everyone in the room yeah
no okay so so sure okay the answer is no
it's a good question to ask and the
answer is 0 because it is not given the
diagram the diagram tells you that right
and in fact as we know like I mean we've
known it for so long it's like dirt but
it's not that's a property is it that's
a property and so therefore just like
every property first day yeah okay now
guys guys be there 23 my question I'm
not going to have the discussion about
like any marks or not anything right you
make a judgment I'm just going to say to
you guys generally speaking what you're
looking for are okay do they have some
properties of a parallelogram they can't
just as we just said assume everything
about a parallelogram so they have some
properties of parallel lines because
they have to be used somewhere stuff
like alternate angles and co interior
angles right and then us there's some
properties about the triangle right so
here are my properties of a triangle
which I've used do you see that um
obviously there are other ways but I
don't know if there's a faster way so
that's that's three things right there
do you understand parallelograms do you
understand parallel lines do you
understand triangles okay and did you
stay all of that there will be you know
finicky bits which maybe it's too maybe
it's three whatever you make a judgment
on your friends paper or then go from
there but that's do you see how we're
crafting a question and when we say our
three marks we are not going to write
the 150 different ways there are to
prove this we're looking for Bajor
categories of thought okay so that's
that and last one here we go 02 yeah
you happy with that you can see there's
some irrelevant information in the
question can tell me can someone tell me
what is a piece of irrelevant
information this constant over here we
don't care about that because if it's
parallel that light can be shifted
anywhere you like the important number
is the gradient right once you've got
that you do it like this you get your x
value out and then you substitute back
in yes yeah that's right and once you've
got it here's my here's my proof there's
the point that I said 5 X comma 2 sorry
let me make it a bit bigger for you
that's my 02 point and if you really
want to see the tangent there it is and
they are looking pretty parallel survey